quero começar com uma pergunta esse meu
silêncio breve deixou alguém pouco
desconfortável curioso deu branco que
foi ele esqueceu a nervoso tô eu vou
voltar e silêncio daqui a pouco então
quero começar contando que nos últimos
25 anos
eu cobri eventos esportivos
absolutamente fantásticos eu comecei a
minha carreira em barcelona quase por
acaso
cumprindo uma olimpíada que é
considerada mais sensacional olimpíada
contemporânea pelo legado que ela deixou
na cidade uma revolução urbana quem vai
hoje a barcelona ainda encontra esse
legado e por uma espécie de construção
de auto estima da espanha numa época em
que geograficamente a espanha estava na
europa mas de fato não estava na europa
era uma prima pobre a espanha fazia a
sua arrancada sua decolagem rumo à
integração europeia o mercado comum
europeu que depois virou união europeia
então a espanha mostrava para o mundo é
o seu novo patamar de grandeza usando os
jogos olímpicos para isso depois de um
lapso de tempo eu fui cobrir olimpíada
de pequim
é uma experiência absolutamente
fantástica numa cidade e exótica onde a
gente não tem acesso à informação porque
enfim eles falam mandarim
nada mais que a gente não fala mandarim
também com uma característica
geopolítica muito interessante a china
em 2008 é consolidar a sua posição de de
player mundial nesse tabuleiro né da
política da economia como uma economia
crescente e um sistema político
deficiente a gente pode até criticar mas
a china como força militar e como força
econômica naquela época em 2008 passava
a ser uma realidade para o mundo e ela
fez a olímpiada justamente para mostrar
para o mundo que ela estava aberta pra
ele que ela podia conversar com o
ocidente
de uma forma bastante saudável aí fomos
pra londres em 2012 uma olimpíada bem
mais familiar com paisagens bem mais
conhecidas com o idioma mais acessível
olímpiada fleumático elegante
tipicamente britânica
eu gosto muito de correr então eu fiz a
maratona de nova iorque completei quatro
horas e meia mais física gay um evento
maravilhoso com 50 mil corredores se
imagina a logística para botar 50 mil
pessoas
pra correr tem fila a fila anda rápido
tem mais de 150 atrações musicais e
culturais no trajeto
a gente vai correr os 42 quilômetros em
uma banda de rock tambores japoneses
samba brasileiro não sei que as coisas
vão acontecendo talvez por isso tenha
demorado tanto para chegar porque é tão
gostoso que está correndo no meio
daquele barulho que a gente tem vontade
de parar para ver os shows em vez de
correr depois fiz a maratona de porto
alegre com muito orgulho o rio deserto
do atacama
corri na patagônia chilena na beira da
praia aqui no remanso adoro correr mas
porque eu tô contando tudo isso pra que
tanta auto-referência né
esse ano o brasil sediou as olimpíadas e
invertendo um pouco essa minha lógica de
cobertura de grandes eventos eu propus
para a empresa onde eu trabalho num
negócio pouco diferente o pedido tem que
saber um pouco e só as paraolimpíadas eu
não quero o bi olímpico
eu vou ficar em casa vendo pela tv como
todo mundo e vou pro rio de janeiro
chegar nas paraolimpíadas eu queria
manter uma certa pureza nesse meu olhar
que também viu a copa do mundo do brasil
os setores a seleção brasileira da
seleção tava lá no set é um então vamos
pular essa parte rapidamente vão voltar
para as paraolimpíadas ea empresa topou
queria manter uma certa virgindade de
percepção porque as paraolimpíadas
muitas vezes são tratadas erroneamente
como um subproduto das olimpíadas já que
a gente já investiu essa grana toda lá
pra fazer ginásio estádio então depois
que as grandes estrelas for embora vamos
deixar os pobrezinhos usarem a lipor por
dez dias porque já está tudo lá mesmo né
investimento já feito
a gente já projeta uma imagem legal de
responsabilidade social para o mundo
então agora libera são vistas assim eu
queria quebrar essa lógica e fui para o
rio
cheguei lá numa noite quente e fui para
o complexo paralímpico e aí foi meu
primeiro choque porque se inverteu uma
lógica que a lógica que a gente vive na
cidade porque ao chegar no complexo
paralímpico da barra da tijuca e eu vi
uma quantidade pra mim inédita de
pessoas com deficiência de cadeirantes
de pessoas amputadas de pessoas com
deficiência visual de pessoas com
problemas cerebrais muito diferente do
que a gente observa a nossa cidade a
gente eventualmente esbarra no
cadeirante no local de trabalho uma
pessoa tem uma deficiência visual
auditiva mas elas são tão minorias que
ela se dilui não é que elas não existam
elas existem
só que elas são invisíveis na cidade
elas estão por trás de portas fechadas
sendo cuidadas o mal cuidadas por
instituições e às vezes por famílias e
às vezes por depósito de seres humanos
que a gente simplesmente não enxerga
esse foi meu primeiro choque ao inverter
a minha lógica de percepção
mas durou pouco porque a visibilidade é
fundamental para a gente acostuma e
olhar e algumas horas depois eu estava
assistindo uma partida de tênis dupla de
tênis feminino em cadeira de rodas
imagina quando que eu ia me propor
assistir um evento desses tão exótico no
meu repertório
mas eu me dei conta em seguida que é uma
coisa muito poderosa acontecendo ali
muito bonita quando eu vi aquelas
mulheres belgas e holandeses jogando
tênis em cadeira de rodas eu vi primeiro
que jogar tênis em cadeira de rodas é
muito mais difícil que jogar tênis em pé
com uma mão elas vão controlando a
cadeira e qual o outro braço ela tem que
acertar a bolinha quem joga tênis hoje
assistiu sabe que às vezes a diferença
de 1 grau numa inclinação de raquete do
corpo é a diferença entre a bolinha na
estratosfera ea bolinha na quadra do
adversário
fui tomado por um sentimento profundo de
admiração quando eu vi aquelas mulheres
jogando eu me dei conta naquela hora que
elas não são pobres vizinhos
elas são atletas de altíssimo nível de
altíssimo rendimento e que trazem algo
que é fundamental cada vez mais na nossa
sociedade para pessoas para indivíduos
para cidades para empresas vão voltar um
pouco no tempo um barbudo britânico que
andou aqui pelo continente a bordo de um
navio senhor charles darwin
aliás um dos mais mal citados cientistas
e pesquisadores da história da
humanidade todo mundo diz que darwin
declarou o seguinte os mais fortes
sobreviverão darwin nunca disse nem tem
até pensar não sei mas eu nunca disse
nem escreveu o le pensamento de dar um
pouquinho demais mesmo para uma potência
de um jornalismo é mas darling disse que
na verdade indivíduos e espécies com
maior capacidade de adaptação vão
prosperar e sobreviver
e foi isso que eu vi nas paraolimpíadas
do rio de janeiro que aliás teve de
acordo com o google analytics o maior
pico de interesse da história das
paraolimpíadas foi no rio de janeiro
pode alguém ousaria dizer qual foi o
esporte mais procurado no google aqui no
brasil futebol né não
o golbol o esporte mais procurado no
google pelos brasileiros durante a para
limitar o que eu tô querendo provar com
isso o interesse pela capacidade de
adaptação como uma qualidade humana ele
vem crescendo e é cada vez mais
fundamental nesse processo todo eu
conheci um cara sem querer ser piegas
aqui forçar a barra que realmente mudou
minha vida
o nome desse cara ricardo alves o
ricardinho ecad um golo de osório e aos
8 gostava de jogar futebol tem uma
inteligência motora fora do comum têm
até hoje e aos oito anos ele perdeu a
visão uma coisa muito rara descolamento
de retina dos dois olhos
o encardido com cego e era um guri
chamados bicos e os rolling stones e que
gostava de jogar futebol porque o
ricardinho vai fazer da vida ele conta
que por um pouco de receio em uma certa
num certo impulso de não machucar os
pais que estavam vendo ele sofrer
ele tomou uma decisão aos nove anos vou
tocar minha vida
pegou sua bicicleta cego e saiu andar de
bicicleta no pátio da casa dele os olhos
é um partido grande e ele passou então a
reconhecer o terreno pelas ângulo pelas
ondulações pela brisa pelos sons caiu
caiu mas crianças que geram caiu também
caiu de carinho caiu e levantou adorava
jogar futebol e tem um primo que deve
ser um cara muito legal que de vez em
quando era casada joga bola com ele mas
era um jogo muito chato porque esse
primo chegava botar a bola no chão e
ricardinho chutava o primo estava no gol
defendido ou não um dia o primo chegou
na casa do ricardinho com uma bola
envolta em um saco plástico de
supermercado e aí deu se a mágica
essa bola caiu no chão e quando a bola
caiu no chão e ricardinho deu conta de
que ele podia ouvir a bola ea partir de
então eles passaram a jogar futebol com
a bola e envolta em um saco plástico ea
vida do ricardinho mudou porque ele
passou a fazer aquilo que ele mais amava
vamos dar um pulo no tempo e vamos
instituto santa luzia em porto alegre
ricardinho descobriu o futebol de 5 que
é um esporte paraolímpico passou a
praticar e hoje o ricardinho o melhor
jogador do mundo nessa modalidade aliás
efe campeão paralímpico fez o gol da
vitória do brasil contra o irã nas
últimas paraolimpíadas
eu fui assisti lá no rio um jogo de
futebol de 5 e é uma viagem no bom
sentido porque os cinco jogadores são
cegos
o goleiro enxerga e atrás do gol tem um
cara que fica dando instruções
qual é o desafio da platéia ficar quieta
porque só dá um grito na platéia é capaz
de levar uma bolada
porque eles seguiam unicamente pelo som
e por alguma coisa que eles não sabem
explicar eu aprendi uma lição muito
poderosa com ricardinho e ele expressa
isso em palavras quando a gente não tem
uma fonte de informação na hora de
decidir uma fonte de informação tão
importante quanto à visão a gente pode
escolher entre dois caminhos às vezes
não há escolha
mas o ricardinho pode escolher se
transformar em vítima da vida e reclamar
ou se tu não tem uma fonte de informação
usa outra ele passou a usar a sua
audição e se transformou num exemplo
mundial de sucesso de superação fazendo
aquilo que ele sempre sonhou aquele
sonho que ele perdeu a infância de ser
jogador da seleção brasileira ele
readquiriu depois da deficiência com uma
coisa que o crédito como sendo meio
mágica meio divina mas a força do
indivíduo ea grande capacidade de
adaptação a gente pode chegar um
pouquinho agora pra falar da cidade
as cidades hoje em dia elas são pensadas
de certa forma para carros e não para
pessoas
as cidades e falo de quase todas que eu
conheço com raríssimas exceções são
muito pouco inclusivas e com isso elas
acabam perdendo a oportunidade de se
tornarem mais leves mais divertidas mais
criativas e mais justas
eu quero aqui parte por um conceito que
eu acho muito interessante eu morei um
ano em israel
e lá a questão da caridade é tratada de
uma outra forma inclusive é um conceito
bíblico não sou um cara religioso mas eu
acho que a bíblia religião podem ser
fontes de ensinamento muito interessante
muito valiosa gente parar de olhar com o
preconceito seja de que lado que a gente
tiver nessa questão essa palavra que vou
dizer pra vocês é sedaka quando a gente
entrou no supermercado num bar em israel
no restaurante uma loja tem um cofrinho
e lá escrito que você dá cá a gente
traduz por caridade não é caridade
a tradução de sedaka é justiça ou seja a
diferença é que a gente não ajuda o
outro
para se sentir melhor para se sentir
superior porque o outro é pobre ea gente
é rico e por que o outro precisa a gente
tem a gente ajude a gente faz por uma
questão de justiça
então ninguém se vangloria ninguém se
sente superior porque ajudando
simplesmente faz inclui porque tem que
fazer e ponto final
essa é uma lição que a gente pode
aprender no planejamento das nossas
cidades
as cidades elas acabam não ouvindo os
seus silêncios e é por isso que no
começo aqui eu fiquei um pouquinho
quieto pra gente perceber e eu também
fui ficando incomodado com o meu próprio
silêncio de que como a gente está
acostumado com determinados padrões e
quando esses padrões são quebrados
a nossa sensação de desconforto e eu
digo a gente precisa de mais desconforto
na nossa cidade
a gente precisa usar nossa capacidade de
adaptação não para se adaptar à
violência não para se adaptar ao arroio
dilúvio esse esgoto a céu aberto a gente
passa por ele 30 dias por dia já tá
achando que é normal
nós nos adaptamos para o bem e para o
mal por pressão externa hoje em dia
temos usado muito mais essa capacidade
de adaptação para nos adaptar ao que não
devemos nos adaptar mas devemos gritar
no entanto fazemos silêncio as coisas
que deveriam nos causar revolta
indignação eu atuo em algumas
instituições aqui que atendem crianças
que são deficientes deficiência
cerebrais graves e eu cada vez que entro
lá eu descobri um novo mundo que não
está acessível a gente precisa procurar
esse mundo esse mundo não vem até a
gente
então pra concluir que eu queria deixar
para vocês como aprendizado disso tudo é
que a cidade sendo um espaço de inclusão
sendo um espaço generoso sendo um espaço
colorido e criativo não está fazendo
favor não tá fazendo bondade não é
questão de ideologia é uma questão de
justiça a cidade porto alegre todas as
cidades precisam cada vez mais aprender
a ouvir os seus silêncios e se incomodar
com eles
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]